welcome everybody hope you're having a
great
evening or morning for very late night
depending on where you are um we've been
having some pretty cool
developments here in the club
i guess my personal favorite is my book
was finally published as you probably
already saw that is the thumbnail
and the link is also in the description
so feel free to go ahead and
um
well show me your love
and we're gonna talk about the game
uh some of the games that are in that
book so the easiest way i can explain my
book is
don't play the game play the opponent i
think that's just the easiest way i can
explain it because
a lot of the books are about chess
theory i've read them i love them you
gotta read them too a lot of the books
are about
chess skills like actual chess skills a
lot of them are about like openings or
end games or like you know puzzles and
my book well my my brother and i we both
wrote the book so i shouldn't say my
book i guess i have to say our book yes
so our book is not just necessarily
skills of chess but it's also how you
can kind of like get on your opponent's
head and
kind of like figure out what they want
and block it and it's kind of funny
because um i also kind of um i
mentioned my specific things to saying
let's just go in the book too because
the opportunity that i had here to teach
kind of helped me grow some of my
methods because initially when i wanted
to teach for the club like this class
instead of chestnut psychology i wanted
to call it how to play a knowing chess
and i guess that wasn't very user
friendly
so
i wanted to put that on my book but then
again you know the word of knowing might
not be as user friendly but that's kind
of the concept so
yeah i hope you enjoy it and let's get
to it
so
um the
first game that i want to show you i
have two games prepared the first game
that i want to show you is um
one of my
one of my i guess
ex countrymen because i'm from iran but
i don't really live there anymore and
i'm not really going back so i guess x
country man yeah let's go with that um
he is i think he just won um the sharjah
open so
this is kind of goes hand in hand
in this specific game he beats my
current country man
jeffrey zhang which i'm a fan of but
this game was too beautiful not to put
it in the game um so this was a very
interesting game because like even
though i um
i don't live in iran anymore i still you
know have some feeling towards it and in
the cover of the book it beautifully
kind of shows that because the art is
like green and red and white which is
the iran flag
i guess that's also italy's flag so yeah
what do you know i do love italy too so
yeah i kind of feel like it's a kind of
a good mix of a bunch of stuff so let's
go ahead and get to it jeffrey jean
versus tabatabae wait my keyboard
doesn't work hold on
there we go it works
so yeah this was a very very interesting
game
in the sense that
these two guys are still pretty young
right jeffrey is young tabatable is
young
and um this i think was right after
jeffrey was like very close to being
super grandmaster like very close to
crossing that 2700 barrier
and um so
jeffrey's
was favored to win and his rating was
like 26 91 tabatabaya was barely 2600
2601 so he was favored to win and he was
so close to crossing it
but
that's not how the game turned out now
is it
so
let's get a little of the opening out of
the way
catalan and
yeah so um there's a lot of different
variations in catalan i feel like if you
want to learn the opening
it's just like way too many things out
there as black i've just played like
this bishop before i've chosen to take
it a bunch of times there are some lines
with like knight c6 a little later
they're just like so many things so if
you are um kind of struggling with
figuring out on what to play against
catalan
you're gonna need a more comprehensive
introduction than just this game so
make sure to double check our own
youtube channel because we have so many
videos there if you're looking for
something you're most likely going to
find it there
all right so bishop e7 let's get out
all right i guess my first question is
well
how do you want to get your pieces out
there's again as i said there are
multiple ways but i kind of want to get
the audience involved and
the live audience the online audience my
i guess in person people
how do you want to get your pieces out
as black
i'm
like both sides castle so you kind of as
black you kind of have to figure out
what you want to do with these
pieces fair point where
it's okay yeah getting the knight out is
good knight c6
right now might it's still doable but um
because a lot of ideas with knight c6
are because you want to take over here
oh my mouse is big and um the idea is
that like right now you could again you
could take it it's very possible uh but
it's kind of white will
in the long run white will get this pawn
back so there's a lot of ideas with
knight e5 a lot of just like ignoring
this for the time being and just trying
to develop then if you go like b5s oh
boy these are getting um
too funny this is getting too much
yes right your rook is just like it's
it's not looking very pretty
simply put
so yeah for that reason um we might be
more cautious when we want to take
dtxt4s
so knight d7 was played again knight c6
possible but you gotta know the theory
if you're gonna
take that c4 pawn you need to know the
opening so knight d7 clean out
sorry i didn't really see the
relationship between knights oh okay
fair point so nice e6 good good point
the idea is that now when i take it i'm
not directly attacked
right so when i actually take this then
later on i could do like a rook v8 the
b5 and it's not as dangerous
okay
uh
kendricks how do i start to learn chess
by myself
well um
i can offer you some different resources
resource number one youtube
versus number one should be youtube and
specifically our own channel youtube
center chess club it's very it's kind of
organized like it has the beginners it
does intermediate just go to the
beginners and start scrolling through if
you are a young audience if you are a
kid well i guess chesskids.com i'm a fan
of their that specific website
um leeches also has pretty nice
video libraries you can you know scroll
there down
um yeah
what else yeah i think that's that's the
that's kind of like how to get started
all right
so nice c6
definitely doable and the relationship
is that it's kind of um
posing a question for the
threats in this
diagonal all right so knight d7 is a
stronger this was played and queen d3
all right now what do we do we still got
to figure out what to do about this
bishop
i'm having trouble hearing you
so you want to push this pawn before you
start considering what to do with this
bishop
possible
yeah definitely possible if you play c6
though then this bishop will kind of be
permanently boxed in
but if you were gonna do c5 it's totally
doable but these this type of pawn
structure and the stuff that's gonna
happen in the center um
it's
it takes some expertise because
um usually when the pawn structures are
like this it's better to have the knight
on c6 so initially if you wanted to play
something like c5 it would be better to
keep this knight from going to d7 and
try to bring it to c6
after you play c5
and there's so many options so it can
get a little confusing so you got to
know what to take when because if not
and if you just like if either white or
black doesn't know how to how to resolve
this tension over here then it can be a
little confusing
and yeah but it's definitely possible
there's nothing wrong with it
yeah exactly simple moves yeah let's get
this bishop
out to
i agree and the other thing is that
after we play b6 we're kind of telling
the opponent like all right look i'm
gonna develop my bishop i'm probably
gonna put it on b7 so
now the opponent has to decide are they
going to keep this tension or are they
going to resolve it and uh jeffrey jung
actually did resolve it which was kind
of a
good idea
because if not when the bishop comes
here now we we're gonna have our own
claim for this pawn and then the center
so i like that it makes perfect sense to
me to take
we're gonna take back but see again when
we take back now this is somewhat of a
target for opponent but it's also kind
of blinding our own bishop right
so i guess that's like the tiny piece of
the strategy
that's if your opponent also also
psychology that if your opponent wants
to develop this um bishop to a specific
square if you can you know immediately
blind it
why not
all right knight c3 let's get the bishop
out knight e5 all right now blackstone
what do you think we should do and i
kind of know that my in-person audience
can't possibly see that i can't help
that sorry
so try to don't look that way look this
way
exactly don't even look at the board
exactly
another piece of advice that i would
give you in a lot of the queen's
queens gambit and a lot of these
uh
catalan a lot of these lines this e4 and
e5 squares are just so important
and
the first few times that i was playing
them as black i didn't realize what was
happening and then opponent just did
like a knight e5
and then just like put like bishop to
you know f4 started developing and they
kind of dominated the center and
it was not very pleasant for me
so
uh doing though unfortunately i don't
think that the borders are still open
but
why not
all right so 95 what should we do about
that
is there anything specific that sorry
what
what night
so yeah you want to bring pressure
understandably
fair um it's definitely doable
but
my reasoning is that i might not know
for sure
where do i want to place this bishop
maybe later on i want to put it on f6
maybe later on it's good here maybe i
want to put a c5 i don't know what i
want to do about this bishop yet but i
do know what i want to do about this
rook
yeah
so it makes sense to especially in the
openings that you might not know for
sure
i mean these players knew what they were
doing in the opening but for for other
players it might not be as clear what's
happening in the opening so if you don't
know what's happening the simplest way
is to develop your pieces purposefully
go for the center
go for the fruit flies and um try your
best to um just put your pieces
in the
most useful place
but at the same time kind of if you have
to choose between which piece to bring
first
then it's uh it would be
kind of you know cool when
um you know your rook
belongs to e8 so put it on the end and
then we can figure out the other piece
does that make sense
all right i feel like i repeated myself
a little but
oh well uh custom wait castantino
constantino tent likes yeah constantino
well um i'm not necessarily a streamer
uh this used to kind of always be a like
in club
you know
the you know just
live public audience but because of
pandemic we kind of mixed it up
so
yeah
it's for everybody whoever can join
perfect
all right
what do you think white should do
also let me give you a little more
insight if we decided to take this
take back night comes and
um
this would be um
not as comfortable for black you see
white gains this file this file and this
diagonal and
there's so many things that are under
attack white pieces are just much more
active
right
this piece like dude that is just like
so active i don't like this for black
this is totally playable but just not
preferred
all right
so that was one line that i wanted to
mention so rookie eight
bishop f4 all right now black to move
what do you think black should oh
never mind
i was trying to scroll down here ah
jesus i'm starting to scroll down here
technology right
all right so pretend you didn't see that
why do you think black played c5 and
actually kind of fun thing uh back when
this game was happened so i'm assuming
like two years ago
yeah two years ago wait was this two
years ago fairly certain this was two
years ago yeah two years ago yay
um
c5 was a novelty
so
yeah what do you think
what do you think about that
i can't hear you
oh all right okay so that's cool um so
style whoa jesus
jumping huh
all right so the idea behind c5 is that
we want to
gain some more control over the center
we want to kind of like create tension
in the center and
we're trying to kind of question all
right what do you want to do about this
pawn
are you going to take it are you going
to defend it
we're just kind of trying to figure out
what the opponent wants to do so
a lot of the times when giving opponent
too many chances they're going to mess
up again probably not in you know 26
2700 level but
eventually they will
if both players play the perfect game
the game would just be a draw so anyways
uh yeah i wouldn't tell you
oh yeah i like it yeah i don't think we
should take that either because after
take the knight could take and then this
square becomes
too uh too good to be true for us
and now we are gaining a lot more peace
activity than white thought
so
um
what platoon f1 and let me tell you a
little bit more about this position as
well
um
we are again we're kind of questioning
the opponent's center
and
as my brother kind of called it it's the
calm before the storm
yeah i don't really get that idea with
the calm before the storm i've never
felt that usually the storm just hits
there's no column before it
so
but then again
all right
um rook fd1
and yeah so the d file is gonna be
opened sooner or later so it's a good
idea for um
opponents to you know start spock stop
piling up those um
those
you know rooks and queens and just start
going for the d file
um
yeah
the other one will also come to c1
now
what should we do about this tension are
we gonna resolve it
oh fancy
there is a tactical issue with it
um when you play c4 you're kind of
forcing up what kind of pushing
opponents to come to f5 and next move
this pawn is also kind of wobbly because
they can actually take it because this
this bishop is um undefended
right
let's say you what are you gonna do how
you can how can you even defend this if
you could play like a b5 b4 immediately
i would actually kind of like that
but
this pawn right now is problematic and
you can't really take it either because
then again you got to figure out what to
do about this knight and if you touch
this knight and the d5 is pulling
falling so it's like a lot of
issues all at once
does that make sense
so yeah we don't want to we we want to
keep this tension here because if we
resolve the tension even by pushing then
opponent is going to form and form a
attack on us
and that would be devastating
so
let's
revisit the subject of taking so why
don't we like this
yeah why don't we why don't you guys
want to take this
i'm sorry what
fair points but if we take and if take
back now we actually have a mini
tactical thing
thank you skaki scotchy scotty
i remember you from last week
all right
where were we
yeah exactly
and this guy drops
yeah you just want a piece
congratulations
so that's why it was also good it's not
just the strategy behind it it's also
the fact that you know there's a little
tactic here now um opponent obviously
didn't take it point knight b5 now what
should we do
i love it and i think the idea is that
if we give this pawn up too easily then
we only have this you know uncomfortable
isolated pawn left and i thought that
pawns are all right
but in the middle game especially
because they provide some space they
provide attacking ideas but
unfortunately that this is not the case
in this position because the bishop
is directly attacking it so knight c5 i
like it we're putting up a nice fight
now i've queen thanks d4 now what do we
do
untitled you're also correct
seagull channel oh i don't know how i
feel about sequels
i don't really have much experience with
them
ah
sorry what
do you want to play yeah why not
possible um
i thought 96 might be a little bit more
within the rhythm
yeah and then you got to move the queen
we could take it i feel like that's all
right too
and this is this is this is doable
i feel like it's much more
convenient for white to have this knight
on d4 than not
however we don't have to take it we
could start with a6 and we could
exchange these knights
and we could you know start getting a
little funny with our central pawn and i
actually like this i think i prefer this
to
this
i am a sucker for peace activity i love
this activity i love just having active
pieces space development it's a little
cliche cliche but i do i feel like
whenever i don't have space or peace
activity
i can't really function well and i just
lose like a kid actually some kids play
better than me when i don't have peace
activity so
yeah
all right
okay let's go back
fun all right
um so
jeffrey did not take queen takes before
i kind of think he should have
but he didn't
he kind of i feel like he wanted to um
he didn't believe that it was like
it's time to kind of throw in the towel
and take the d4 pawn he still wanted to
keep on fighting and he wanted to i
think he still had dreams for a nice
attack in the king side
uh dreams
anyways
so we have three what do you think we
should do as black
um
getting bishop to d6 hmm
the first thing that i'm just like oh
maybe not is take
take
and take
that for it means a no-no and there's
like take early on too that's probably
also gonna be ouch
so yeah careful with your loose pieces
what else do you got for me
let me let me show you a little thing
like remember how this night started a
nice journey
well maybe we could continue this
night's journey
what can we do with that knight
sorry what
yeah
yep yep i like this 94. it feels a
little um
weird to be moving the same piece over
and over again but it actually makes a
lot of sense um
here i think opponents
should have considered taking again
but now it's even more dangerous because
with bishop c5 now uh position is
getting a little stinky
so
yeah i don't know i don't know if i
would actually advise for knight takes
d4 right now you feel a little feels a
little off
um
so
opponent's fight knight d3
which is simply prophylactic move to
well to stop bishop c5
and the idea is that all right i'm
stopping bishop c5 and
on top of that
i am getting attacked by a fruit fly
it's very vicious
i think it likes my tea
every week this like
they love my tea it's good tea but i
don't like sharing
all right
from next week i'm gonna bring my cat so
it can catch the fruit flies watch me
i'm sorry what but you can't touch it
peachy could
yeah yeah the cats i thought i thought
you said he wasn't going to attention
he's going to earn his tuna
he's creative when he has to be
let's put it that way i trimmed his
nails today though maybe that was the
wrong idea
anyways let's get back to the game
although his majesty the cat is indeed
in the back cover of the book and i
believe somewhere in the book too i
haven't seen the book i don't know
but um i believe that he was included in
there because
there wouldn't be a book without the cat
the one thing that i'm slightly
heartbroken about is that my publisher
told me that i also did t-shirts and
mugs of me and my brother but not the
cat if there was cat mug i would
actually buy it
i i like i would like to have my cat on
a mug
but a drawing of my cat on the mop
because that drawing was really
beautiful
i experienced that today
a little ptsd but yeah yeah cats cats
are kitties are great all right
we took a little nice break went down a
little rabbit hole
so
um
yeah so 90 turns kind of a prophylactic
move because it slaps the bishop c5 but
at the same time we don't necessarily
need bishop c5
we can simply do the rook c8
right
bishop c5 is cool but
it's not like if you don't do bishop c5
you're gonna lose the game bishop c5
would be nice but opponent is stopping
it and if we were to play bishop c5 this
knight c7s would get very uncomfortable
exactly so let's do this rook c8
cool and here i think i think this was
where the position started to go a
little belly up with bishop bishop
street i don't get bishop h3 i think
that's that's was the crucial mistake
point
so what do you think is actually a good
move for whites
yeah i think one of these pawns has to
fall
wait why a7
well why not the d4 one though
yeah that's a good one
bishop c5 and then bishop e3
and
uh black feels a little bit more
comfortable and you don't want to take
that
fyi because then
these center hanging pawns they're
they're co
it's you know they're called hanging
pawns but they're not hanging they're
dominating so
yeah
i guess there's like boss palms not
hanging puns anyways um yeah i you
shouldn't take that so even if you play
bishop e3 then you can simply just
develop and the you know white i think
would be fine
in the end game if the queens were to
get exchanged because
isolated pawn you know and the end game
is not as strong as we would want it to
be
but again i don't think that i think
this is still very playable for both
sides so let's just go back let's go
back to
not knight d4 and knight a7
possible but i feel like it kind of
pushes the rook even to c2
and i don't know how i feel about that i
like my position of black i feel like
i'm more comfortable with this position
than if you were to tell
tank
and
bishop v3 i feel like i'm more
comfortable on
that position when i still had my pawn
on d4 and d5 rather than this one
so
yeah i think knight d4 should have been
played
sorry jeffrey
all right
so yeah um white kind of messed up a
little played bishop h3 black query
click the drug c4 and white somehow
continued to
make a little mess out of the position
knight e5 knight e5 is wrong and i'll
tell you why in a second now
the best move is b3
with the idea of all right now b3 you're
questioning where does the stroke wants
to go surprisingly rox c3 is the best
one
and we are going to liquidate that
pawn if you take we're going to take it
back with the pawn now this pawn is
about to you know
come say some hello to your first drink
and yeah
this is just so beautiful i love it
i can't wait to have a position like
this
anyways uh but unfortunately did not
this did not happen in the game but b3
should have happened and then white
should be taking on d4 this was white's
best chance at this position black is
still doing pretty fine but white still
has fighting chances however after
knight e5 white completely lost that
fighting chance what do you think is the
best move for black now
and
just a small
uh hint we don't care if they take we
can take back and our pawns become
really cool so
thank you
fair point
so we don't want to touch the rook what
else would you like to develop
thank you sebastian in the chat
ah a3 what you doing my friend
ah a6
possible but be be careful because we
don't want to lose this pawn and the
rook if i'm if i'm going to give up the
rook i don't want to give up
the d4 pawn so
where does that leave us
yeah simple moves defend your pawn it's
just uncomfortable
but i guess
fair point it's also kind of funny
because there's so many things it's so
crowded in the middle of the board right
it's like a giant pile of mess which is
better for black actually and white is
kind of naturally playing it good over
here
but
unfortunately it doesn't really matter
because like this is like already like
black it's like four pounds better right
now so
haha
i don't think it really matters at that
point perhaps jeffrey was in a bad mood
it happens i've seen super grandmasters
blunder for
no apparent reason
but anyways not as often as you would
like to see him but
yeah
but like so if take we take back and
we're simply just gonna kick this knight
around and we're gonna start pushing and
oh my god this is such a beautiful
position
hey
so i think white's best shot would be to
play b3
and then if you move the rook try to tag
over here and like this would still i
think this would be white's best shot
because finding the d3 move is actually
that's pretty easy never mind i was
going to say find the detriment might
still be a little challenging
take but you open up your bishop your
knight is active your rook is still kind
of in the middle of the board and you
can go try to trap this one
all right i'm going to end this line
here because i feel like the more i go
into it
it's gonna get even better
so yeah but you see peace activity peace
activity is
i think truly the most important thing
in chess
don't quote me on that just yet give it
give it a little bit more time but i
think that the pizza activity is truly
at least one of the most important
things
you know what i'm going to stick to it
peace activity is the most important
thing in chess there i said it i'm
putting on my
my water bottle my gavel
there we go
all right yeah peace activity
seriously if you don't have peace
activity how can you even play chess
all right so white point e3
questionable
of course we're gonna eat the other
night because today is the day that we
hate our rooks
we're just gonna throw them around
uh rookie five was actually quite
beautiful bishop e5 and then boom knight
g5 another little tiny fork
queen gotta move and boom we take that
and we're gonna take the other one
opening up this king
and um yeah it's very kind of it's
kind of weird and it's so clear that how
important does this pawn on d4 was
and that's one of the reasons that we
cared so much about that pawn on d4 we
defended it we even give we wanted to
give up exchange for it upon it didn't
accept it so we gave it up a different
way
you know it was one of those beautiful
um moments now i the black truly is
winning white doesn't really have much
to do but it's still tricky black still
has to be able to find
good moves like if you just start
exchanging stuff off that's not going to
work as well as you wanted to again this
is still
quite advantageous but it's not
as easy as
for example something like activating
your coin yeah all right so we activated
the queen take take and here opponent
played knight d6 alright so
let's take a moment and think
what should we do
we are in a
triple three-way fork
so
what do you think
i agree so let's say we take the f2
let's say king goes to f1 then what do
we do
i agree with e takes f2
so we take and my question is what if
king goes to f1
try a meal smoothie from smoothie with
at least 10. sorry i was trying to see
how is it going from this end
and
thank you for that
i guess so why not
i'll send them a pill
um
whoa alan you got this whoa
whoa
whoa
no
you got this roxy too woof that was
beautiful
and actually this happened in the game
and this is kind of the only winning
move
the idea is simple moves i just want to
give you a tiny little chick and then
push and make a new little queen little
[ __ ] will be checkmate so
yeah tiny checks
no this is this is quite this was quite
beautiful i really like the ending of it
especially
ah
beautiful right yeah yeah if you eat the
queen
little bit of a check over here a little
bit of a checkmate there
yeah
and if you don't take that if you take
the other way i'm assuming queen b5
oh queenie two is easier yeah why not i
mean it's the same same concept
we're gonna make double queens
and
fun right
all right
let's go back and after all right so
uh bishop and six is also possible but
it kind of gives you the opponent and
taking over here
and if you take now king f2 and this
opponent can get quite slippery
so if you don't want a slippery
opponents which we don't you shouldn't
you should do the store moves this rook
is is very important it's more important
than our queen right now so let's bring
it here let's defend the f pawn and then
we can do the bishop a6
all right uh there was another thing oh
if king goes to h1 again we can do rook
c2 we could do queen c6
i'm
kind of thinking we can also do this but
i'm not the biggest fan of it because
there's queen g2 and like this could get
quite slippery so uh if you are going if
king gets one i the easiest one is again
grook c2 the idea is if you take over
here all right sure now i'm going to
give you check and then i'm going to
give you check
and this will be checkmate
take
take
take
wait wait i messed up i kind of wanted
to direct you to there we go
now i want to do like a tiny bit of a
checkmate there
and this is the windmill so it's quite
beautiful you can just eat over here you
can eat that there's so many things to
eat this is winning by the way
ideally we can do a checkmate but if not
we're still winning so rook c2
beautifully done and uh what what else
was there if take i'm assuming
same ideas i can just do rook c2 i don't
i don't even think we should worry about
this at all because the queen just joins
the party so yeah
all right well this was one of the games
that i wanted to talk about
and this game was quite beautiful
because
it's in a chapter i believe called grab
it while you can
and it's funny because in that chapter
there is another that chapter is
actually in the teaser of the book so if
you open the link that is to the book uh
you're going to see that there's a
teaser pdf of it thank you there's a
teacher pdf of it and so if you open
that the seventh chapter i believe is
the grab it while you can and the idea
is that
i'm a pawn eater i love pawns i love
material you shouldn't just pass it by
you should care about it but again
with respect to peace activity if you
eat material and it gives you peace
activity why not but if you're kind of
giving up material to get peace activity
why not but if you're eating material
and your pieces are you know getting
passive then that's kind of a no-no type
of situation so that's one of the things
that i really really like about um
let's see should we do another quick
game
how how how are we feeling
do we want to do another game i do have
it ready
all right well we'll probably go a
little faster on this one
because i i really like this one too
this one is a game that anand played
uh when did he play this 1997.
a year before i was born
yeah
and um all right so
also the opponent was at 26.60
so
i
am going to leave that at that
so
um this was was this one was very fun
this one was kind of
the analysis was mainly done with my
brother uh so the credit completely goes
to him
and he had a lot of fun with this one
because my brother's style is very like
punchy and you know like kicking and
bitey
over the chest and um
so he he really had fun with this so
let's keep going um
all right so far so good we all kind of
know the theory for the scandinavian
we're going to continue
with
yeah sorry an ant this is a different
anant that was the world champion sorry
man
it's kind of funny how they're multiple
anands i've never met another doorstep
actually that's not true i've met like
tiny door sons baby dorchester but i've
never like had a full-on conversation
with another dorso so if there is you
know maybe we should have a facebook
group chat of dorsals
all right um bishop c4 pretty pretty
normal right
which number five i'm um
yeah bishop of five we kind of gotta do
it too bishop g4 is also another one
but i think in this specific case h3
makes it a little bit more comfortable
for us because if there's like a
different lines of bishop d2 first or
bishop c4 first to just keep that those
in mind uh bishop five knight t5
everything is good this is again
somewhat theory so i don't really um
if you don't play it and if you have
questions in scandinavian again check
the tent list chess club video library
on youtube
if you can't find what you're looking
for there uh come over here and do the
video library on the leeches i actually
like that too
so
now my first question to you why tamu
what you gonna do
greg that's kind of funny chess is fun
if not why are you here
why am i here well i know why i'm here
but
all right so what what should white do
i'm kind of cutting a lot of the
commentary on this game which you can
find in the book
but yeah because i really want us to get
to the end of it and i don't want to
rush the ending because the ending is
quite beautiful
there should be somewhere
is your
darts were dishes somewhere
somewhere fair point uh possibly but how
about hunting this bishop down
yeah
anand the bishop hunter
all right um i like this because we are
kind of questioning the
the location of this bishop like
seriously dude what do you want to do
with it do you want to come to e4 or
we'll poke it again
so now uh knight d7 was played
take
h5 would be a little um too extra
because now knight takes e5 if you take
back takes that with the check
and that's going to be painful so we
don't we don't want to give up free
gifts to our opponents
not at least over the boards i've had
the opponents who like when i was
playing like world championships they
gave me like the token of their country
it was funny because i remember i played
like a girl from us back in like 20 2007
or 2009 was it i think it was 2009 and
she was i think sarah chiang i think i
saw her again a few years back in one of
the colleges events and she gave me like
a coin um from america like a coin the
one dollar coins it was really cute yeah
i think i still have that somewhere so i
the opponents did give souvenirs before
the game not over the board
i mean
at least they didn't like it when they
gave over the board gifts
so don't give gifts to your opponent
over the board
so 97 knight takes d7 now we push
because there is no more gifts bishop
before and now this one i always kind of
thought when the bishop gets to e4 you
know the f3 might be the easiest way to
to kick it back so what do you guys
think what should we do right now and
it's kind of weird because
there is a suggestion of castle by the
engine which i wouldn't do i don't also
wouldn't really recommend it unless you
really really know
going on
that's kind of a funny comment because
it reminds me whenever my mom whenever i
was going to like games that i was a
little stressed over or even when i was
when i lost when i saw my mom last like
a few weeks back when i was leaving she
she kind of like gave a kiss on my hand
so that it was going to stay for a while
but she would always kind of do that
when i was going to games when i was
stressed you like kissed behind my hand
and her like lipstick would stay i was
really cute so
yeah
basically
why wouldn't you move this
yeah
possibly why not just bring up the rook
you're not gonna castle this place so
might as well bring in the rook
all right yeah i like this bishop i feel
like this is just kind of pushing it and
now the rook is just like all right now
i'm gonna you know
say a little hi to your king possibly uh
it's kind of funny because castling
would be totally weird because now
bishop d2 and now you gotta have to deal
with this you gotta have to deal with
that you gotta have to figure out what
to do with the bishop but if the bishop
moves then we got another attacks of
bishop and the bishop is kinda getting
trapped now
kind of fun now isn't it
and um this is like plus four ha
even if the bishop didn't get fully
trapped uh opponent's position upon his
king got really naked
so
um
i guess a better word is wonderful
i'm gonna go with naked
um so bishop g2
rookie three
and
now
what do you think black should do
i'm sorry what
develop the bishop
possibly but you also have to be mindful
that this bishop might be getting
trapped
so i think the best moment is just play
bishop d5
get rid of that bishop just deal with
the problem
then you can consider developing your
other pieces
that's what i would recommend
but hey what do i know
i'm not a 2660.
that was bad shade
all right so opponent's point knight b6
it's logical but i feel like this this
is something that's gonna it's gonna be
kind of like a that like i guess the
thorn
that's you know when the thorn goes in
your hand it really hurts for a while i
feel like that's the this like that
bishop on f3 is gonna just be a
pain in the torn and okay i can't
continue but anyways so let's just get
rid of that bishop
so
yeah
oh a pain in your sleeve i guess that's
the
that's the version
oh
yeah
yeah
okay uh so knight b6
and um
all right we want to keep our bishop all
right we don't care about this truck so
i guess the theme of today if we wanted
to rename this why i like the name but
if it was to be renamed it's like
we don't like rooks we don't care about
our rooks
or yeah
so because with the last one we did a
exchange sacrifice and we're doing
another one now the idea is that f3 is
really really brilliant i don't know if
i would do it in my own game
because i think g3 kind of makes sense
right because your g3 take take
you're not going to take it because i'm
going to do bishop d2 you're probably
going to do bishop d5 bishop d2 clean a4
you feel like this is you know kind of
advantageous you're going to do cleaning
2 you're going to want to do like c4 why
not but it's about that tempo that's
when you play rook g3 you give your
opponent the tempo to save this bishop
so that's the problem so
understanding that all right even if i
play f3
even if you were to take it
this bishop will fall i think that's
such a huge part of it that maybe people
won't remember
so yeah maybe they just won't pay
attention to you so it won't be much of
remembering to be fair there is like
little tactical stuff like bishop a3
here
that i don't know if people would
actually see but bishop v3 is quite
interesting best move is bishop c1
because if you take it then a plant is
going to take over here
and we don't want to weaken our own
position and then we're just gonna
simply hunt this bishop down
and yummy bishops yeah this is winning
for whites
uh this is very advantageous for whites
so
yeah that was one thing i wanted to talk
about the other one was if not knight e3
if knight takes c3
we would simply take back and we would
just bring bishop d2 and then we'll just
do king f2 this bishop will fall
a little weird but it's a little on edge
but it's quite doable white is better
i think this would be black's kind of
best shot
so yeah
all right let's go back to the real game
after f3 bishop b4 all right cool king
f2 the idea of king of two is again
we don't care about the stroke
we are enjoying our game without without
the stroke if you take it cool i'll
simply take back this will fall
so it's not the next we're not actually
sacrificing per se in exchange per se
but we're kind of giving up a rook for
two pieces
the second piece is just going to be
you know e10 after a little while
so king f2
uh in the game black took bishop c3 the
take back and
queen c3 was played if knight c3
simple moves queen e1 and now this is
also kind of
um
pinned so
yeah queen tag c3 and then boom rook b1
we're activating our other rook
we're still going to want to eat this
in the game opponent to queen d4 and
again anand was like nah this this guy
can stay here you can keep attacking it
i'm gonna activate my other piece which
was very beautifully done
now king g2 the problem with king g2 is
simply take take take and you didn't
really you know
win two pieces we only got one
and now we're actually down in exchange
and some pawns and some peace activity
and they're gonna wanna castle soon this
is not good i don't want that we don't
want a blunder not just yet
so rook b7 rook d8 and
this move was so
cool slash weird i didn't think about it
when i was looking at this game i feel
like i mean at least not at the first
one if i actually sat down and started
thinking perhaps i could have had the
idea but this is just one of those weird
moves so what do you think white should
do
alan you said you remember the game so
feel free to join hints maybe don't give
up the exact move but please do give
hints
how are we doing
whoa drook stock on e6 i mean
it would be illegal
c2 ha
rook f7 whoa whoa whoa guys we want to
do logical moves
we don't hate our rooks that much
bishop g6
actually i do see some logic to that
interesting because if queen d1 bishop
f7 king f8
bishop a3 if 97 didn't exist or c5
didn't exist i would say sure
i guess if knight wasn't i mean let's
say if the knight was over here i would
say yeah sure why not but the 97 kind of
messes with your plants
so we said take her there
what else you got
well the thing is if you play c4 what if
they just take over here we take they're
going to take this
so
i kind of like the idea why they're
activating the queen to want to eat
stuff
or what ana did which is poof mind
blowing h6
it's weird it's truly weird the the
thing is if right now joel like pushes
the pawn
then we can simply take that
this is a little different because
whoa sorry because we can take it to the
rook
whoa
wait why am i
this okay sorry
i'm i feel like i'm being a little weird
can't do checkmate
few moves there we go
check it
bring it
take it
and voila
and we couldn't exactly do this if we
played bishop g6 then because if take
rookie six king runs if we take just
king runs we don't really have that
extra oomph with unbroke g7 so
yeah that wouldn't have worked for that
reason
okay
i compared playing bishop g6 right now
with taking on g6 right now
okay
take king take whoa we're gonna take
this first check and then we're gonna
give the other check and then we're
gonna kind of do a little shift to the
king and we're going to include our
other bishop and now this is checkmates
and like two moves four's checkmate
yeah exactly
thank you
so that's why we needed that h6 and
after that all right let's go back so
um
h6 if opponent didn't didn't play g6 and
the other thing is if they choke we
would simply just take back now this is
under attack this is under tank this is
under attack just like a bunch of wobbly
stuff
so after h6 joel just took
and ananda's like all right
let's go cuckoo bananas
bishop g6
and to be fair this is um truly
horrifying because if you take over here
again i'm gonna have her key six
and then i'm gonna have hold on let's do
this first bishop h6 and then i'm gonna
do checkmate
so this h6 also gave your bishop another
purpose
this was truly beautiful i really really
love this
and so if not rookies sorry what
it's okay i would usually i would pause
here and ask the audience to kind of
start thinking or kind of out of time so
i'm kind of rushing through it because i
really wanted to show this game
and yeah so bishop g6 very beautiful
and in the game poor joel kind of just
was like all right let's just go 97.
let's just cut our losses take take
and even now uh um anand
could simply try to save the bishop but
he goes rook d3 now the idea is if you
take all right i'm gonna take this and
then the bishop falls and then it's like
uh
i have just an extra bishop right
so
in the game uh he just don't drook d8
take take sample moves bishop d3 quite
torturesome and here black just resigned
because white simply will eat this
and uh the bishop is truly trapped and
the king is also in a very uncomfortable
position bunch of checks are gonna start
popping from left and right so white is
just totally winning
yeah
this was one of my personal favorite
games and my brother's personal favorite
games because he actually chose this
game but it's a very beautiful one i
really liked especially that like h6 and
bishop g6 and that was just such a nice
dance i truly think that this was just
kind of dancing with the pieces rather
than chess so
yeah well um that's all i have for you
for tonight i hope you guys will like
guys and gals will
look into the book and like it and get
it and get my t-shirt on my mug too i
don't know how i feel about that just
yet but
i've done few other
videos previously about the upcoming
book so we will probably
figure something out about those two i
might just come and put those in the
chat in the comments later
and um
yeah i'll see you next week and if
you're gonna be around make sure to tune
in for twitch in about 10 minutes
exactly our switch to twitch join our
twitch and bringer your games to be
analyzed we're going to be there for
about an hour hour and a half so
see you there
[Music]
you